thank you very much today we'll be going
over the Rory Lopez alright we'll show
you what you should play how not to play
it and we'll get on with the games
alright alright so in our first game my
student Michael had the black pieces
okay so we'll see how he plays the were
little plays okay
efore a 5 9 f3 Knight to c6 and now when
white brings is Bishop to b5 ok it
doesn't happen in this game this is the
Roy Lopez alright so a very typical
response for black is to play a 6
alright can everybody agree with that
alright so if you were playing white in
this position there are two very common
moves here one is superior than the
other okay so so what what are one of
the two moves you're thinking about
capture the night
excellent so so that's the move that is
highly recommended and now you're
doubling blacks pawns here ok so now
he's got double pawns
everybody understand alright so he gave
him double pawns but he's got two
bishops now alright and they're both
active all right so where do you think
this Bishop wants to go really really
bad a g4 right but the reason why I
can't go to g4 right now is it's not his
turn right all right so so everybody's
like well I can bring out my knight like
a castle but I think that's what he can
play the move Bishop to g4 dangerous
okay very very dangerous I don't know if
I've showed this yet I don't think I
have but white could actually if he's
like oh well please go away black
doesn't even have to move his Bishop to
h5 here he can simply play the move
h5 all right so now everybody at home
shouting take the bishop take the bishop
all right so he takes and now black
takes and you know he's opening up this
h-file so after Knight takes pawn right
what does black do to thread checkmate
Queen to h4 threatening checkmate not
just one checkmate but two checkmates
Queen to h2 checkmate
Queen to h1 checkmate so now we have to
figure out a move that stops both of the
checkmates okay so if you're like well
let's just play Knight takes pawn well
that does stop one checkmate but not the
other
okay so we need a move that stops both
the checkmates is there any I see one
you see it f3 there's actually two moves
yes yeah you couple f3 or f4 genius all
right
but f3 is the most common and then we'll
put they're both horrible and now and
now okay so he just played f3
so now as king can flee to safety if the
Queen gobs goes to h2 or each one okay
obviously the King can't go there now
because the Queen's got the square right
okay so so how do we want to stop the
King from fleeing this way and I bet
everyone
I bet I know what you're going to say
well let's check them so who would we
check them with the bishop but does that
work no he plays d4 so let's not check
him with the bishop alright so we want
to stop the King from getting to f2
right
so what move can we play pawn to g3
excellent and now now he's in a world of
hurt now he's back on the two checkmates
and so play rook to e1 that stops one of
the checkmates but not the second
so what move Queen to h1 checkmate help
resigns yeah resigns we recommended a
long time ago okay resigns was
recommended when he castled and allowed
his bishop to come to g4 so what moves
should we play as white here h3 if you
all want to play super good this is the
move you would make you would play h3
and now the whole purpose of all of this
is after d4 and takes and takes let's
say we trade off all the pieces here
okay so okay let's say this is the
position you get to sew so in the
position you trade it off your D pawn
for his EEP on this black D pawn for his
EEP on the white D pawn for the black
epon okay and you trade off all the
other material okay and you get to this
position alright why is this favorable
for white than for black
cause of these junkie double ponds right
all right so so these guys cannot create
a passed pawn even though that's not
true but they these foursome can't do it
unless white really messes up and I'll
show you the example how white really
messes up but white can easily create a
passed pawn so so if white wants to
create pass pawn pretends that these
Kings can't move okay how would he
create a passed pawn in this position
all right so so white has a pawn
majority one two three four one two who
do you think which which ones of these
white spawns are going to become a queen
you think are going to get past this
little guy this guy this guy or this guy
who do you think has the best chance to
become a passed pawn a passed pawn is
basically when there's no pawns on the
same file and no pawns on the adjourn
e-files on the lining files right there
so he can just go and no pawn can take
him no punk and get in his way he's got
a clear shot that's why he's a passed
pawn so who do you think's got the best
chance the e pawn right alright so how
would we go about trying to create a
passed pawn here for white
you push the majority forward okay yeah
King can't move and then we just keep
moving the pawns and now we got a passed
pawn okay
Black's the only way to create a passed
pawn in this position is to do this old
trick and it has nothing to do with
having an extra pawn here all right so
if it's black to move here
has anybody seen this pawn trick before
all right so we have two Stephen have
you ever seen this pawn trick all right
so it's going to be news to somebody all
right okay so it's black to move and
well assuming this pawn wasn't here
protect the moving win let's just say
for the sake of everything now it's
black to move and win okay all right
black to move here okay so he's got
these three pawns lined up and these
three pawns lined up it has to be this
exact position or else the trick won't
work okay so he's really close to
becoming a queen okay but he's got these
three little guys right in front of them
unfortunately so we need to distract
them alright so if you haven't seen the
puzzle it's kind of tough to figure out
but I'll give you a hint the first move
well well I'll give you a hint the first
move is pushing the middle pawn okay so
now so now obviously if I take and I
take back you take back you retake back
nothing gained nothing lost okay so
that's not the solution okay we're going
to force one of these three pawns
through okay so so when we play b3 here
let's say he takes with the a pawn okay
so now of these two pawns
okay the a pawn or the C pawn which do
you think has a better chance of
becoming a queen possibly the one that
did it you know he's got a point on the
same line as him or the one where he
doesn't have a pawn on the same Lane as
him the a point because look there's no
there's nobody here to stop him alright
the C point is stopping that C pawn so
so if this guy is so valuable right you
probably don't want to don't want to
lose him okay so you then push this guy
alright and so so while I'm threatening
to take the B to pawn here so better
take it and now what move should we make
with this a pond well there's actually
two moves you can make with it but but
yeah the superior one is Wow and then
he's got a clear shot to victory okay so
so if you look at that position it
doesn't matter which way you take with
here you could take with the C pond and
then you just advance the opposite one
okay and then you got the clear shot the
victory alright so that's why you play
the Rory Lopez exchange variation okay
all right so so here's the game
Michael Scholl he had the white pieces
here and I've told them this about a
million times here all right so what do
you think he plays after a six obviously
obviously and so now so now it's so now
you just asking black to just attack you
again and no questions and that Bishop
here and now if black really wanted to
say
I'm trade I'm getting rid of your
LightSquared Bishop no matter what what
move would he play here like no matter
what you're not going to have a light
square bishop anymore
Knight to a5 excellent okay loses a pawn
so don't play that let's see let's see
if it really loses a pawn and there's no
way I'm getting this pawn back alright
good luck
it looks like I'm getting my pawn back
I'm getting it back I'm doing it yeah
with interest interesting yeah yeah
you're too young to understand interest
right now but it's good it's the best if
you're getting it it's very good alright
so you can do that alright but but
you'll have to alright and so now your
Bishop is on this long diagonal so you
could have just attacking f7 if you
wanted to put them there in the first
place you should have just played Bishop
to c4 as we'll see in the next game
alright so so his opponent just calmly
plays Knight f6 okay so castle now
Knight takes out the pawn so white could
play d4 or he could just get his rook
over on this action file here and attack
the odd the night
so when Knight goes backwards
so now yeah this pawn is in a pin it's
not going to do much here so we could
just attack it okay but white decides to
take it alright
so now takes so once again this Knight
is in a pin it's not going anywhere we
can just attack it again okay but you
can't wait to take it so rook takes e5
check Bishop Bishop e7 so which piece is
in a pin here
the bishop good what should we do to the
pin pieces attack I'm good so what move
should we make here yeah Queen e2 or e1
it's undetermined which one we should
actually go to because maybe even though
we probably do want the rook on a1 to
eventually go to e1 we might want to
just put our Queen to e1 in case he
starts attacking our rook okay but I
mean it really doesn't matter but yeah
we should play our Queen on this file so
it prevents them from castling so Queen
e2 our Queen to e1 Queen e1 might give
this rook a better more spaces to go to
all right but instead he's like I'm
going to play a trick and this is not a
trick I went to a Scholastic tournament
this weekend and it's like whenever they
attack something okay they get a big
grin on their face like they're like
they're doing a trick is this Queen f3
is this a trick no his attack in the
rook but it's not really a trick it's
just an attack no but it's not it's not
like a honk I are our regular here he he
was the best new player and uh I see one
kid grinning ear-to-ear when he attacked
his bishop with the rook it and yet it's
like it's not it's not a trick buddy
he's just going
move is a bishop and then you got
nothing alright so obviously he just
plays here and that was your attack way
to go okay right so you know c6 c6 is
the best so d4 and so now what can black
do and now he's very happy
Castle alright but just because you're
in a castle doesn't mean you're going to
be necessarily safe here as we'll see
all right
so Bishop attacks the knight so now
Bishop attacks the rook here so first
things first is he takes the dude even
though it's in a pin and then Queen
takes and now we have a decision
everybody knows what what move I would
make in this position right I would just
take the Queen and now his pawns are all
garbage and I would play rook here
mm-hmm I play rook there and everything
would be okay and if he plays rook the
e8 and he gets a big smile on his face
what move what wouldn't move would I
make here no I went well Knight to c3
but then he plays that move alright good
and then I'm going to go here and pump
into there good excellent so you play
Knight to c3 here to stop the checkmate
okay all right sounds good
and then white ball the computers got a
love white here
what are you going to do with it yes yes
as one of our well it doesn't even like
the computer doesn't know what it's
talking about sometimes yeah so so so
the reason why they apparently like
black in that position is because
they'll have the open G file all right
all right so instead of taking Queen
takes as it should
white decides he's going to play rook to
f5 he's on the attack so we didn't want
to trade anybody okay
so now black plays our queen the g6
failing to see the Queen to h6 thread
checkmate and also Queen takes H
whatever h2 down there so when he plays
Queen to g6 now White's like I'm going
to attack you all right h4 and now he's
like oh I should have play there in the
first place so now he's attacking this H
pawn and Queen check all right let's see
if he cares I don't think he's going to
care all right he does care okay so he
plays Knight to c3 good all right
yeah yeah so you better care yeah he
better care better care yeah as suffice
threatening a big nasty scary check down
there you better do something to prevent
it yeah yeah especially when it when
it's going to end in checkmate yes yes
excellent
all right so Bishop the b7 so now white
white doesn't have to worry about any of
his any of blacks attacks so now he can
proceed with his own attack which which
square are a lot of his pieces going
after right now
f7 the weakest square in chess all right
so let's take it rook takes so blacks
like I don't care whatever pig so Queen
takes check and now the King moves over
this unfortunate is not checkmate
because the rook can come and get me
that's a bummer though so now so now
what do you think white should do play
here
all right so what do you suggest Julian
I had a for night-night
efore alright so I like just taking
everything alright but but he plays rook
to e1 because because he's like this is
going to be checkmate so so he can't
resist threatening checkmate okay which
I understand right so black has a one
good move in this position the rest are
garbage okay rook f8 is a highly
recommended here okay
highly recommend it alright so
yeah so unfortunately unfortunately this
because black is not in check right now
you can do whatever you want including
devastating Queen to c1 checkmate
okay so so he so black has a decent idea
like I want to trade Queens or oil but
he just doesn't go about it the right
way so so he plays his rook all the way
up to to check here which once again is
no good
he needs to be taking stuff take stuff
it's always fun okay and then it's like
it's not even a trick it's a good move
all right yeah so let's say let's say he
wants to save this bishop somehow and
you don't want to save it like Bishop
the sea egg do you know yeah or you
could just be be like Julian and just
just humiliate these guys checkmate you
so when you have this back row checkmate
and play a lot of cool things can happen
so if you plays rook the b8 here now you
have a lot of different ways you can win
basically if you look this is under
attack one way it'd be really funny if
we could attack it a second way and
attack something else at the same time
that's the trick okay and that's a real
trick that's something you can really
smile about because there's no matter
what he does he's got to lose a piece
that's when you need to be smiling and
slamming the pieces not not not oh I
attacked you alright so so so let's name
some ways we can start attacking this
dark-squared bishop and winning it
I agree yeah or you can just play Knight
to e4 all right there's a lot of cool
ways and you no matter what when he
moves this Queen we take well we of
course we take with the night we don't
want to trade when we're on the attack
all right but those are just some ideas
okay but you got to take stuff all right
so anyway so after Queen to f6 he loves
this check but by checking and trading
the rooks it relieved all the pressure
all right so now he's just like okay
you're out so now do you think he's
finally going to take this pawn here yes
all right better late than never okay so
so let's see what's going to happen so
his bishops under attack so there's a
difference there's a couple different
play Bishop the a8 Bishop the c8
or you can just bring his queen over
here and up whatever he's set so
suspicious move even more suspicious
taking it okay yeah yeah yeah yeah so
obviously in this booty wants to play c5
so we can play C for and trap the bishop
all right so takes takes so he just
wants to take and now he might get into
a bishop of opposite color endgame which
are always drawers so oh so and I'll
explain why in a minute here all right
so so if they can stop from being
checkmated here he might have a chance
to draw even though he's down to pawns
but we'll see
so Queen to f8 here g3 he likes it back
better over there again so just going
back and forth you got to make some kind
of progress though all right so he just
played a 5 2 / 2 ax to protect this a
pawn but what was the a pawn doing it
was protecting the other point
Oh
well what are you afraid of yeah
possibly but but whatever all right so
so after a five y can just take and now
he's a know no trouble because he can
just play Bishop back and I will protect
the Queen all right
and so see for g65 and now black just
gave up and you probably shouldn't give
up in this position because yep
you have chances for perpetual check
with the Queen and if you do trade off
the Queen's possibly uh a draw as well
but but black start here there's no way
you can stop this pawn and he might be
right
so he gave up all right on ceremoniously
okay so that was a bummer all right so
so my student got the win there but
let's see if he can stop when they play
a Bishop to c4 okay so instead of
playing Bishop to b5 right if you have
no intention of taking this Knight you
can just go there right away okay
without giving black all these free
moves okay with Bishop to c4 all right
so let's see how this one goes okay so
so black improved from last week because
he knows now never to play this Knight
to f6 move so that was good alright so
now he knows Bishop to c5 much better
alright so white castles and now we can
play Knight f6 with no fear of Knight to
g5 because if white would play Knight to
g5 black and just Castle the safety then
okay so white plays rook to e1 black
castles
white plays d3h 6 so we stopping this
Bishop and knight from coming in so he's
feeling pretty good
so now white plays move Knight to h4 ok
so who thinks that h4 that that looks
like a grandmaster move that that's what
a grandmaster would play anybody no no
no what about most B players you think
most B players will be like make two
each for ya
h4 it looks interesting ok so 9 is short
so so 1 in chess you're supposed to
never put your Knights on the edge of
the board right and plus it's an
unprotected piece in the line of a
dangerous piece I mean you're just
asking for trouble the reason why he
played it is because he wants to get a
quick checkmate here somehow yes
so d5 would be a great move here cause
after pawn takes d5 black is even better
so so if you look at this Bishop what's
he aiming at f2 right so we're going to
be really cool if our knight could come
in and attack f2 would that be pretty
cool love it you know and now this
nights hanging we're threatening this we
got the life ok
or an ith for d5 pawn takes Knight to g4
and then I'll take and I'm now
threatening threatening yet checkmate in
two moves baby maybe just give it up
I'll go with your own little threat you
know what I'm just going to laugh so
hard at well you know what no I'm not
even going to laugh I'm just going to
just go I could take I might even play
Knight to a5 I'm going to take here
obviously I'm going to take here and
then the computer is going to stay calm
or +100 a comer negative five and a half
all right yeah that's pretty good
all right so let's get back to the board
if we can all right so so those are just
some ideas when they when they play
funny moves like that
just uh just try to try to attack them
okay all right Knight okay but but when
you don't punish them it makes their
weak moves look awesome then okay
because he does have a threat of Knight
to g6 here okay obvious he's not going
to play it now but but he does have a
threat
see if he plays Knight to g6 black's F
pawn is in a pin right now and can't
take it all right
so Queen to f3 is feeling pretty good so
black now attacks it he should be
putting his knight down there okay and
attacking f2 but okay but he can't
resist attacking the Queen so I
understand I mean I probably would - all
right so now Queen over there and now
Knight to d4 so now he's threatening
this guy
and this big check all right so he's got
a lot of stuff going on so when white
plays h3 all right so here's the moment
of truth for black here okay there's a
lot of stuff going on his up bishops
under attack is Knights in the center
coming toward here or here okay but
White's Queen is on the same file as the
King so it could get dangerous
alright so black decides to be a macho
man here and it doesn't work out for him
so he's like I'm so good at chess I'm
just going to take you alright and and
this surprised shocked white but he's
like okay whatever a little did you know
now he's guys looks fort but
unfortunately White has a mad counter
play on the Kings side here obviously
Julian knows no possibly but that's okay
that's that's immaterial all right so
what does white play to threaten
checkmate here he doesn't even care
about these rooks
so 9f5 does threaten checkmate yeah and
it might be but that's not as fun
anybody
you see in this Bishop takes h6 can't
capture pain pieces can't capture ya so
now h5 would be a be a chance but it
would fail to the same move he's about
to play so he's like I'm going to play
g6
so yeah he played it okay he might as
well just taking a rook to be honest
with you okay so g6
so ask yourself what is protecting g6
it's a trick question
nothing is protecting g6 but then you're
like hey what about that point on f7 and
what about it okay it's in a pin it
can't move out of the pin so so
everybody at home should now know the
checkmate here Queen takes check King
move and now what move do you make the
checkmate black and now he's got it go
ahead you can say it Queen to g7
checkmate okay Kings can't capture
protected pieces so after Knight h5 I'm
just going to go I'm just going to go
there anyway
I'm not I'm not going to be careful I'm
going right there
well I'm going to be a little careful
I'm going to be so careful I'm going to
look at the computer I'm going to go to
the restroom and look up stock fish here
no it's not no I I'm up I just a teach
just teach no man yeah it went from so
yeah coin the g4 it looks okay that way
I attack the night and I protect my
night yeah I have fun
yeah but I queen up six might stop I
gotta attack it
I just protect okay and yep and then
Queen takes Queen takes and now what
would black do to get all his material
back and probably all ya with interest
yeah yes check and then check again and
then black would be winning just a
little bit but yep so that's that's how
the the game didn't go as they played
incorrectly but but black was still in
it even though he was being attacked at
the end all right all right we're going
to make way for Maurice Ashley's ax
analyze this class and hopefully you
come back next week thank you
you